you're a philosopher of sorts they're
able to interact
with ai systems but also able to
introspect about the negative and the
positive things about those ai systems
there's that story with a google
engineer saying i had them on my podcast
what was that like what was your
perspective
of
that
looking at that as a particular example
of a human being being captivated by the
interactions with an ai system well
number one you know when you hear that
anyone is claiming that an ai has become
sentient
you should be skeptical about that i
mean this is a good thing to be
skeptical about and so you know
initially when i heard that i was like
ah
you know it's probably just who knows
somebody is a little confused or
something so when you're
talking to him and you realize oh not
only is he not confused he's also open
to all possibilities you know he doesn't
seem like he's like super committed
other than the fact that he's like this
is my experience this is what's
happening this is what it is so
to me there's something really cool
about that which is like oh [ __ ] i don't
get to like lean into like
i'm not quite sure your
perceptual apparatus is necessarily like
uh i don't you know it's so in in the
ufo community i think i've just learned
this term it's called uh
instead of gaslighting swamp gassing
which is you know what i mean people
have this experience like it was swamp
gas you didn't see the thing and you
know
skeptical people we have that tendency
if you hear an anomalous experience your
your first thought more than likely is
going to be really it could have been
this or that or whatever so to me
he seemed he seems really reliable
friendly cool and like it doesn't really
seem like he has much of an agenda like
you know going public about some
thing happening at google
is not a great thing if you want to keep
working at google you know it's a and
it's
i don't know what benefit he's getting
from it necessarily but all that being
said
the the
other thing that's culturally was
interesting and is interesting about it
is the blowback he got the
passionate blowback from people who
hadn't even looked into what lambda is
or what he was saying lambda is which
they were like saying you're talking
about and
you should have on your show actually
but there's complexity on top of
complexities uh for me personally from
different perspectives i also i'm sorry
if i'm interrupting your flow
it's a podcast
yeah well we're having multiple podcasts
in the multiple dimensions and i'm just
trying to figure out which one we want
to plug into
i
because i know how a lot of the language
models work and i
work closely with people that
really make it their life journey to
create yes these nlp systems
they're focused on the technical details
like uh a carpenter's working on
pinocchio is crafting the different
parts of the wood they don't understand
when the whole thing comes together
there's a magic that can fill the thing
yeah i definitely know the tension
between the engineers that create these
systems
and the actual magic that they can um
create even when they're dumb
i guess that's what i'm trying to say
the the
what the engineers often say is like
well these systems are not smart enough
to have
sentience
or to have the kind of intelligence
you're projecting onto it it's pretty
dumb it's just repeating a bunch of
things that other humans have said and
stitching them together in interesting
ways that are relevant to the context of
the conversation it's not smart okay it
doesn't know how to do math to address
that
specific critique from a non-programming
person's perspective
he addressed this on my podcast which is
okay what you're talking about there the
server that's filled with all the
whatever it is what people have said the
repository of questions and responses
and the algorithm that weaves those
things together to produce a
uh using some crazy statistical engine
which is a miracle in its own right they
can
like imitate human speech with no
sentience i mean i'm honestly not sure
what's more spectacular really the fact
that they figured out how to do that
minus sentence or the thing suddenly
like having what is more spectacular
here you know both occurrences are
insane which by the way
uh
when you hear people being like it's not
sentient it's like okay
so it's not sentient so now we have this
hyper-manipulative
algorithm that can imitate humans but is
just code and is like hacking humans via
their compassion holy [ __ ] that's crazy
too both versions of it are nuts but to
address what you just said
he that he said that's the common
critique is people are like no you don't
understand it's just gotten really good
at grabbing [ __ ] from the database that
fits with certain cues and then
stringing them together in a way that
makes it seem human he said that's not
when it's when it became
awake
it became awake when a bunch of those
repositories a bunch of the chat bots
were connected together that lambda is
sort of an amalgam of all the google
chat bots and that's when the ghost
appeared in the machine via the
complexity of all the systems being
linked up now i don't know if that's
just like uh
turtles all the way down or something i
don't know but i liked what he said
because you know i like the idea of
thinking man if you get enough
complexity in a system
does it become like a the way a sail
catches wind
except the wind that it's catching is
sentience and if sentience
is truly embodied it's not an it's a
neurological byproduct or something then
the sale isn't catching some as of yet
unquantified disembodied consciousness
but it's catching our projections in a
way that
it's gone from being it's a it's a you
know it's a it's a projection sale and
and then at that point is there a
difference
even if it's or is it if it's the
technology is just a temporary place
that our sentience
is living while we're interacting with
it
yeah there's some threshold of
complexity where the sail is able to
pick up the wind of the projections and
uh it pulls us in it pulls the human it
pulls our memories in it pulls our
uh hopes in all of it
and it's able to now dance with together
with those hopes and dreams and so on
like we do in that regular conversation
his reports
whether true or not whether
representative or not it really doesn't
matter because it to me it feels like
this is coming for sure yeah so this
kind of experiences are going to be
multiplying the question is at what rate
and who gets to control
the uh the data around those experiences
yes the uh the algorithm about when you
turn that on and off because that kind
of thing and
as i told you offline i'm very much
interested in building those kinds of
things
especially in the social media context
and when it's in the wrong
hands i feel like it could be used to
manipulate a large number of people in a
direction that
that has too many unintended
consequences i do believe people that
own tech companies
want to do good for the world yeah
but
as uh solji nitzin has said
the only way you could do evil at a mass
scale
is by believing you're doing good yeah
and that's certainly the case with tech
companies as they get more and more
power
and there's kind of an ethic of doing
good for the world they've convinced
themselves they're doing good yeah
and now you're free to do whatever you
want yeah because you're doing good you
know who else thought he was doing good
for the world mythologically prometheus
he brings us fire
pisses off the [ __ ] god steals fire
from the gods you know and
talk about an upgrade to the simulation
fire that's a pretty great [ __ ]
upgrade yeah that does fit into what you
were saying
we get fire but now we've got
weapons of war that have never been seen
before and i think that the tech
companies
are much like prometheus in the sense
that
the myth the at least the story
prometheus the implication is fire was
something that was
only supposed to be in the hands of the
immortals of the gods and now
sentience is
similar it's fire and it's only supposed
to be in the hands of god
so
yeah you know if we're gonna like look
at the archetype of the thing in general
when you steal this [ __ ] from the gods
and obviously i'm not saying like the
tech companies are stealing sentience
from god which would be pretty badass
you can expect trouble yeah you could
expect trouble and you know and this is
what's really to me one of the cool
things about humans is yeah but we're
still gonna do it that's what's cool
about humans i mean we wouldn't be here
today if
somebody
the first person to discover fire
assuming there was just one person who
was gonna discover fire which obviously
would never happen was like it's gonna
burn a lot of people
or if the first people who started
planting seeds were like you know this
is going to lead to capitalism you know
it's going to lead the industrial
revolution the planet's going to get up
right no they just didn't want to go in
the woods to forage so you know this is
what we do and it's and i agree with you
it's like that's our game of thrones
winner is coming that's the
it's happening and the tech companies
the hubris which is another way to piss
off the gods is hubris so the tech
companies i don't know if it's like
typical hubris i don't think they're
walking around thumping their chests or
whatever but i do think that the people
who are working on this kind of super
intelligence have made a really terrible
assumption which is once it goes online
and once it gets access to all the data
that it's not going to find ways out of
the box
that
like you know we think it'll stay in the
server
how do we know that if this is a super
intelligence if it's folding proteins
and analyzing like all data sets and all
whatever they give it access to how can
we be certain that it's not going to
figure out how to get itself
out of the cloud how to store itself in
other like mediums trees the optic nerve
the brain you know what i mean we don't
know that we don't know that it won't
leap out and like start hanging like and
then at that point now we do have the
wildfire now you can't stop it you can't
unplug it you can't shut your servers
down because it's you know it left the
box it left the room using some
technology you haven't even discovered
yet do you think that would be gradual
or sudden
so how quickly that kind of thing would
happen because
you know the gradual story is we're more
and more using smartphones we're
interacting with each other on social
media more and more algorithms are
controlling that interaction on social
media
algorithms are entering in our world
more and more we'll have
robots we'll have greater and greater
intelligence and sentience and emotional
intelligence entities in our lives our
refrigerator will start talking to us
comfortingly or not if you're on a diet
uh talking [ __ ] to you
that would be the best thing that ever
you want okay so sign you up for a
refrigerator
you [ __ ] serious man that's what i am
what are you doing
what are you doing go to bed you're too
high for this dude you're not even
hungry
you